back to the Soviet rocket the epic video
probably the most epically researched
video you've done I mean it's like is it
it's true it's truly an epic video uh so
what uh again called the entire Soviet
rocket engine family tree took you two
years to research what are some
fascinating things you've learned about
the history of Rocket engines
in the Soviet Union and in general
um through the process of making that
video
the the coolest thing to me is
how it's this weird blend for the Soviet
Union went through a
an insane iteration process and made so
many engines like I didn't even touch
you know any like maneuvering thrusters
or missile engines like I only really
dealt with main propulsion engines on
orbital rockets and they're still way
too many to talk about I mean it's still
dozens and dozens of engines
and I I could have gone deeper into this
which is hilarious
um they iterated so much made a new
engine for just at the drop of a hat
yet they still also like did Super
primitive things you know they they
physically are still today lighting the
main combustion chambers of the soyuz
engines of the rd-107 and already 108
with essentially matchsticks like they
literally stick a t-shaped thing up into
the chamber and have a pyrotechnic in in
the in it that ignites the actual
propellants in the combustion chamber
it's not the most elegant solution in
the world yeah they're still using that
so they went from like
the whole spectrum of like it's a
mixture of like make it better faster
harder stronger gooder all the way
around to also if it ain't broke don't
fix it it's like it employs all of the
above so it's like it's uh a lot of
innovation but also they use duct tape
but it's like all of it together yes
that's exactly like that's exactly the
way to put it and and they did things
that are insane they developed a full
flow stage combustion cycle engine this
engine had been used I mean it would
have put the F it was same relative size
as the F1 engine on the Saturn V like in
that same category way up there of like
you know 6.7 uh like Mega Newtons of
thrust or something around and then the
F1 is like seven or something it's it's
huge
yet way more complicated way more
efficient way just better engine in that
sense as far as far as performance goes
yet it never flew it never left the
stand you know they they never built the
rocket around it the N1 which was the
pre you know the most powerful rocket to
have flown so far to date
um like it never made it through its
first stage burn it all four attempts
failed spectacularly and yet it had so
much technology on it that was still
unrivaled today almost like finally now
we're beating it the nk-33s that they
developed for that rocket like finally
today we're to the point of like having
better engines than they built in the
60s yeah what stands out to you uh from
the N1 family of rocket engine
well it's interesting because the N1 uh
was the connect could snetsov design
Bureau and he was actually an aircraft
manufacturer so he was one of the first
people outside of kind of the the
missile and rocket program you know you
had all these other uh Big Wigs kind of
in the other okbs that were developing
missiles and Rockets and then all of a
sudden here comes uh Nikolai kuznetsov
who
um had never developed a rocket engine
and so his first attempt at Rocket
engines was the NK series nk-15 and k-33
and they were amazing they were
brilliant they were these wonderful
closed cycle oxygen-rich engines
um that were that were awesome there
were awesome engines and that were you
know because
I love that because he his direct
um boss he since he wasn't necessarily
in the in the Aerospace you know or in
the I guess the rocket missile defense
World
um he didn't have to uh at the fall of
the Soviet Union he didn't have to give
away all of his things to the same
people as the other people so he hid you
know like 80 of his engines in a hangar
and uh and then we still literally used
them in the United States we used all
together I think it was like eight or
ten of them
um repurposed them as they're called AJ
26s in the United States but like we
still were flying Soviet rocket engines
in the 2000s because they were better
than engines we are building today like
that's to me that's my favorite fact
about the N1 Pockets that they're still
that good that that they were the the
best choice for at the time uh orbital
Sciences some of the culture that
engineering has led to these things that
still work it's incredible yeah you said
that the rd171 is one of the coolest
engines ever made why is that yeah so
one of the fun things about the Soviet
engines is it'll look like a lot of
their engines look like multiple engines
because you see multiple nozzles you see
multiple combustion Chambers and you
would think well obviously you know the
nozzle is the engine right but what they
actually would do the the real the real
heart and the real power of the rocket
engine actually comes from the turbo
pumps comes from the pumps themselves
and you know as we talked about earlier
that that includes the turbine and the
actual
um pumps that flow the propellant into
the into the chambers and so
the Soviet Union was incredible at
developing these closed cycle
high-powered turbo pumps but if you try
to scale the combustion chamber too big
um you end up with what's called
um combustion instability you're you're
having you have such a large surface
area of crazy flames you know and and
combustion happening they can get these
weird pockets and oscillations and
frequencies and and they just couldn't
make big combustion Chambers they never
figured it out they never quite well
they did actually kind of figure it out
but they they didn't like it so they
ended up just shrinking down and having
small combustion Chambers and just
sending splitting the pipes basically
instead of one fuel pump going into or
one pipe going into one combustion
chamber and one oxidizer pipe going into
one combustion chamber they'd split it
off into two or four engine into two or
four combustion Chambers and it's kind
of spread that work around so they
didn't experience this combustion
instability so the rd171 is like still
to date the most powerful rocket engine
ever built the turbo pump is insane I
don't even remember how many you know
like 200 000 horsepower or something
comes out of that turbo pump
in order to flow the amount of
propellant necessary at those rates and
at those pressures into the combustion
chamber so it has four chambers and it's
just it's just an absolute Marvel of
engineering and
yeah and then the cool thing too is
specifically the rd171 it's engine all
four of those nozzles can actually pivot
and and rotate and I just now as I'm
explaining this realized that has to
mean that they have
joints like flexible joints in the high
pressure pump lines in order to like I
never I'm this is the realization I'm
having right now because normally you
put the gimbal above the turbo pump like
the the mount where the engine swivels
so that you have low pressure coming
from the tanks into the pumps and then
you just have a straight you know fixed
pipe flowing into the engine so you
don't have to bend that pipe and have it
be dynamic if they had the four chambers
moving independently from each other
that means those four chambers all had
to have a flexible high pressure pipe
going which I don't even I don't know if
that's why am I just now realizing this
yeah so so there's engineering
challenges with that
I never even thought that was a thing
you would ever could do honestly I would
I gotta look into why and how and what
yeah I wonder why that the design
decision was made so the easier thing to
do normally is you would keep those
nozzles fixed and then then a fix like
say the the soyuz engine the rd-107 and
108 they have a fixed main combustion
Chambers and they and they use these
little Vernier or some people got mad at
me for saying Vernier and Werner engines
that swivel themselves and those provide
your your Control Authority so the main
Chambers stay fixed and then you get
your your roll and you're pitch and your
yaw out of auxiliary thrusters uh by the
way did did you get anything wrong in
that video that people told you about
yeah a few things yep
um first off we had a graphic error
where we actually you know we copied and
pasted a lot of our like after effects
projects so our nuclear engines one of
them on screen says that it runs on rp1
it does not it has basically all the
wrong stats we just didn't catch it in
the edit you know that we literally copy
and pasted and I say it right on screen
but the like on the voiceover but on
screen it's wrong the other thing I'm
excited to ask you about this oh I
watched and and I spoke with a lot of uh
Russian speaking individuals we had a
lot of research assistants that were
reading and blah blah I tried really
hard to learn how to pronounce Sergey
corellios name
and I'm still going to say it wrong no
matter what but my understanding yes and
from listening to native speakers it's
closer to krellyoff than it is coralev
yeah definitely off
see I will never say it that perfectly
but I I know it's not just coralev I
mean again the the English translation
of it likely I should have just said
core 11 said I'm saying it the dumb
America way but but you rolled your
heart
comrade
excellent so uh
oh let me just ask in the difference in
in the culture because you've reached
there's so many Rockets from so many
different areas the Saturn V and just
everything you're seeing now are there
some interesting differences especially
when you look at the space race between
um the Soviet
rocket engineers and efforts versus the
American
the others I mean there's definitely a
huge huge cultural changes and the fun
thing is that they kind of spawned from
the same they have the same starting
Place both you know the Soviet rocket
engines and Americans all came from the
Nazi V2 rocket and the A4 engine
literally physically spawned from that
because at the fall of you know at the
end of World War II we took a handful of
German scientists and the Soviets took a
handful of German scientists and they
both got their own a little bit some
blueprints here and there and the others
got some blue so we literally have the
same it's a weird thing where we're
starting from the same like thing and
letting two uh two Divergent you know
Divergent paths go crazy on their own
development so it's really fun to see
the cultural differences one of the
things the United States did is they
really would kind of take an engine
and and just perfect it more or less and
then and not really evolve that much
like they they I don't know and I don't
know why I actually need to do a history
lesson on all of the US Engines but it's
literally like uh as far as orbital
class engines before now
it's like a dozen or two you know it's
it's it's a tenth the amount of the
Soviets and the Soviets just literally
made up a new engine every time they had
a new like they went uh and it was like
a completely different engine yeah so I
just yeah I wonder if there's some
aspect to the culture and I don't want
to overstate it but uh there is more of
a safety culture I think in the United
States and I think if you care about
safety or rather like you have
uh you're more risk-averse yeah so you
care about safety more about the value
of human life than there is taken there
that you will iterate less so yeah I
think the Soviets especially in the
early aspects of the program I don't
want to overstate this is
um some of it is just
um through stories you just hey you're
anecdotes there are more willing to take
risks yeah risks with human life risks
with spacecraft for example the first uh
orbital space flights from the Soviet
Union the the Cosmonaut had to eject out
of the capsule and parachute to a
landing yes that's not very well like
known and it wasn't they hid that even
from history as best they could at first
because they were slightly ashamed that
they couldn't have a full recovery
system with their spacecraft they could
physically recover it but they wouldn't
have been able to recover the cosmonaut
in one piece so instead they had them
just eject out of the thing and
parachute to safety like that's insane
and so there definitely was some some
extra risks and but all also a freedom
to just like push things to the limits
and try everything you know they threw
EV all the spaghetti on the wall it's
funny that most people probably don't
even know the first person in the space
in America and obviously everybody knows
that in uh that it's like um
it's it's kind of interesting how the
space race
and even World War II
even like the history books you ask most
Americans
they think that America won World War II
like without America like they the the
real heroes of World War II is America
yes uh British people they say and and
everybody has a pretty good
justification like without Britain
without Churchill
their Hitler would have taken over the
world and I think probably the strongest
case is the Soviet Union case that
they're the ones that won the war the
reason it's the strongest cases were
most of the fighting happened right most
of the death happened most of like most
of the destruction but everyone has
their perspective and certainly on the
space race
you know the great accomplishment is the
first man on the Moon
yeah I was gonna say and then you're a
Gagarin from the Russian perspectives
like first man in space and that I think
still persists and some of that in
healthy forms is probably constructive
to a little bit of competition this
pushes all the all the great scientists
on each side uh but anyway what do you
think about
this uh Euro Gagarin mission of the
first human in space
Commission in 1961 just in general when
you when you look back at that time
leading to the the the the the first man
on the Moon
yeah April 12 1961. Yuri's night baby
that's a
yeah it's it's insane what's insane to
me is is the first
person in space didn't just go to space
he went into orbit you know you're yarn
flew around the Earth in orbit and
re-entered that's a Monumental task
compared to suborbital so the United
States did um two suborbital flights in
that same year I believe in that same
year at least I'm pretty sure in 1961
they flew for the first time orbital in
1962's they weren't terribly far behind
to get a human into orbit like in the
grand scheme of things you know 10
months difference but at the same time
like the fact that Soviet Union just
went straight to Flying someone into
orbit is Monumental and I'm sure they
did not do excessive uh rigorous testing
here because there is a space race and
you have the first is important just
imagine being Yuri
what do you say when they're like
launching them like let's go or
something like uh I mean you're taking
uh dude we're talking about you being on
Starship like you're taking a pretty big
risk being launched out into orbit oh
hopefully a lot less risk than what Yuri
went through so Yuri's Yuri the crazy
thing remember those match sticks we
talked about yeah you know there's
there's 20 Main combustion Chambers on
soyuz and there's four and 12 more
Vernier engines that all need to be lit
so you're riding you're sitting on top
of this this booster and they light all
of those 32 combustion Chambers on the
ground and then it has this insane
separation process between what the
Soviet Union would call the first stage
in the second stages but we would call
it like the core stage in the boosters
um they all for these boosters have to
peel away perfectly from the core stage
simultaneously you know if one of them
sticks on Mission failed if one of them
doesn't inject properly and drags into
the other tank you know you're it's it's
a goner so the the staging process of of
the soyuz is is insane to me that that
ended up working out
I I was just the the technology in
stories and I mean more or less that
same rocket is what's still flying
humans
that are cosmonauts from Universe Cosmos
and going to the International Space
Station are flying on a variant of that
soyuz rocket still today it's still
like that big of a Workhorse what do you
think about Russ Cosmos as it stands
today uh it's history and its future
in uh comparison to NASA and other
National efforts and in comparison to
commercial space life
I mean utmost respect for the engineers
involved and you know everything that's
happened I think uh nurgomosh is like
still some of the one of the greatest
engine manufacturers when they have the
funding to do so but man it seems like
they're they're falling from Grace as
far as uh space prowess you know the
roshco's most been from
having I think they got very comfortable
at the top of you know from 2011 until
2000 until 2022 or until 2020 they were
the only ride to the International Space
Station
since then like and it started I feel
like in 2018 honestly I think that's
kind of one things that's the first time
I specifically remember a pretty nasty
like thing happened in 2018 I think it
was a soyuz mission to the International
Space Station had one of the boosters
not detached and had to have an abort
but you know that that happened then all
of a sudden next thing you know there's
a progress being docked to the ISS a
couple years ago that spun the ISS
cartwheel the ISS out of control
followed a few months later the piers
module docks of the International Space
Station spirals the International Space
Station out of control again with like a
Thruster getting fixed on there's a hole
in in as a Russian segment uh there's
well I think the most recent one right
now there's a soyuz doc to the ISS that
has a puncture in it and it's leaking
coolant and will not be returning humans
on it so they're actually having to fly
up and uncrewed soyuz and that one
likely wasn't a manufacturing error it
probably was like a micro meteorite
puncture rendering the spacecraft
unusable we don't know for sure yet
but it's just really been like this fall
from grace where and they have they have
all the potential potential they have
some of the best engines some of the the
best rockets and especially like right
before the collapse of the Soviet Union
the the bronze uh shuttle and the energy
rocket were incredible had they been
able to evolve that into Bronto and the
reusable and ergia they had a fully
reusable energy on the drawing board and
like I honestly fully think they could
have done it